all right
[Music]
free brand is the platform of
Largest e-commerce in Latin America
with solutions for shipping payments
credits and classified for all
that operate through our
platform we increased 75% the
downloads in the last year
mainly for two reasons a
because we were adding many features
but I think the most important is that
we put a lot of effort into it and we put ourselves
as an objective to reduce the weight of
our apps and recover the performance
We have 65% of users with less than
2 gigabytes of ram memory and approximately
20% with less than 1 giga therefore
our user base has
very low range devices in your
majority and therefore we have to
program our applications thinking
in them that are the majority we launch the
Android version go first what
we did was focus on the
tools that the
Android platform being clicked on
density and for architecture and try
check what we do is eliminate
all the code that is not needed to
the app
then we focus on the resources
and the images the images the
we converted all to web and where we could
and the code we took out all the bookstores
externally that we did not need
we managed to reduce 70% of the size of
our app from 38 megs to 10 megabytes
although this size is dynamic the low
of weight of our application had
incredible and immediate effects as well
we upload this new version to the store in
our facilities grew by 43
hundred and our links all put
18% which gave us 25 percent
of growth in our are repeated are
rate for us the experience of
user is the most important when
some user has a crash is not only
one less operation but that is a
user who is not happy with his
experience with free market that's why it's
that we look very closely at the information
that provides us with white android als in what
related to thanks to be able
attack them by taking pictures throughout the
information that you provide us by such
we can improve the god or ride retention
lower them to Nestor lower the amount
negative reviews and climb incredibly
the positive ones
the day we started to see android
whitense in the app we detect that
we had a wake bloc that affects
directly to the battery of the
quite high users and thanks to this
we could solve it and in one case
particular that affected many
users and we managed to lower the crash raid
from point 3 percent to point 15% with
Android white als we have a vision
of the quality of the app in all
moment the advice I would give to
any developer that is
thinking about making some application for the
market as latin america that lends
attention mainly to the weight of
for download and installed and the
app performance today android
It has a lot of tools
to be able to do that in a very
easier and simple so it's at
reach of all
[Music]